we're thrilled to have right here
kicking off our guest line today
uh a man who co-wrote along with tim
cato of the athletic a piece that uh
certainly caught my attention and
everybody else in the nba about some
dissension in the dallas mavericks front
office
and uh and then now smash cut to three
days later
general manager and coach route sam
emmick of the athletic here on the rich
eisen show how are you sam
rick's doing great thanks for having me
you bet so let's
get right into this here uh are you i
would say i i
imagine are you surprised or unsurprised
that these moves took place i mean you
were obviously
talking about the dissension in there
but um
man holy smokes three days later
exactly what do you got for me i'm
surprised i'm surprised the scope of it
and the
the dramatic effect i guess and the uh
the quickness of it the the part that i
guess isn't surprising is that
um to me it's funny ever when you write
these kinds of stories and obviously
you know folks like mark are not happy
that this stuff gets out it becomes this
a bit of a witch hunt to figure out hey
where did this come from and and there's
part of me that
you know this is one of those where you
look at it as a reporter and you say
okay this was coming from everywhere it
was so widespread so widely known
just not out publicly yet that that that
i think is reflective of
the moves that have been made since and
the the ripple effect
of it now the timeline here rich is is
fascinating too though because
admittedly
when we drop the story monday morning
what we've learned since then
is that donnie nelson had already been
fired he just hadn't told anybody
um and so you know on the media side of
things
you know it's a funny timeline there um
but
they let me listen there's a bigger
story here about
you know mark's decision to bring a
professional gambler into his culture
and that bothered a lot of people and
then it only got worse from there
so let's get into that part for for
those who
might not have read your piece and again
the piece in the athletic that you
co-wrote with tim cato
inside the mavericks front office mark
cuban's shadow gm is causing a rift with
luka doncic that was the headline
um put a few more meat on the bones
right there
a professional gambler uh is brought
into
the front office of the dallas mavericks
yeah so back in 2018 is when formerly uh
bob vulgaris is working with the maps
but by his own contention
he had essentially a freelance
relationship before that so he's worked
with them for quite some time
and my understanding our understanding
is that
if you go back all the way to that time
you know kind of the mid
20 teams you have mavericks employees
that
understandably are looking sideways at
this higher uh and this i think you know
again
you've seen the nba get cozier and
cozier with the gambling industry this
was kind of the
you know a sign that it was trending in
that direction anyway but nonetheless
you have all these basketball folks that
think that's uh a complicated you know
controversial fit but then more
importantly
it's the combination of bob's
personality bob style
the fact that he had a direct line to
cuban the fact that if folks like donnie
nelson who had been there for a very
long time
over time came to the conclusion that
they didn't have the juice that they had
before
and that um you know certain moves that
they wanted to happen weren't happening
because
you know vulgaris was advising
differently and and it
starts at donny and it goes all the way
down through the front office and the
scouting department
and and these frustrations grew and grew
and kind of obviously came to a head a
couple days ago
well cuban um when you asked him about
vulgaris um uh and his involvement
in the piece he was quoted i really like
what bob brings to the table he does a
great job of supporting rick
and the front office with unique data
insights and added that bob has a great
grasp of a.i
and that's not allen iverson and the
opportunities it creates for gaining an
advantage which is important to me but
he isn't any more influential than any
other data source
on the team that was a quote cuban gave
you uh for your piece
uh the quote he had about your piece
when he retweeted on twitter
was total bs
um how do you square those comments
um it's funny rich i've been asked a lot
you know quite a few times the past
couple days
about the reaction to that i mean part
of it i i know mark pretty well
um and admit you know on this one the
way we work at our company is tim cato
is our beat writer
and so in this instance he interfaced
with mark you know directly but i've
dealt with mark for
a decade plus and i like mark yeah um i
i
i shrugged when i saw the tweet i mean
my first feeling was
essentially that it was performance
theater and
it's it's kind of what he has to say um
little did i know i mean listen
you know we say all the time on social
media that certain tweets
you know didn't hold up very well that
one didn't hold up very well
and you know you see uh everything has
been exposed the past couple days
just how rot with issues they were
internally so
um it's fine i get it um you know but
i obviously stand by and feel very good
about the reporting
and and again we've seen what's happened
since so uh sam emic at the athletic
here on the rich eisen show
so at the time that this article came
out
the general manager who was reported to
be at odds with the front office had
already been
fired after a quarter century damn near
quarter century on the job
and is is carlisle's departure exactly
um
because uh vulgaris the shadow gm as you
referred to him in your piece
has one out is that is that what what
carl
has total clarity there and then
fairness journalistically you know
certainly
marx you know has taken great exception
with the phrase shadow gm
but it's you know you identify it
however you want he had a a ton of power
it was making a lot of calls but
with rick um and having not talked to
him personally
it's you know i think there's a few dots
here that are really
safe and fair to connect which is like
we reported
the tension between rick and luca
was really widely known and to rick's
credit like we wrote
you know he's been really adaptable once
he sees a star player that essentially
is so great
that he knows he's not going to win the
personal battle with that star player
rick has a knack for
kind of standing down a little bit
seceding a little bit of control
finding a way to make it work and he had
done that with luca but there was still
there were issues there so then you know
you take away
a long-time supporter and advocate in
donnie nelson
and i think it's it's obvious that was a
factor in the way rick
looked at the situation because when it
comes to rick
and bob vulgaris our understanding was
that again
rick had been adaptable if i had to
guess i mean for a proud coach who's
accomplished a lot
and is very good at what he does that
had to be a tough pill to swallow
because rich i'm not talking about
just hearing you know the analytics guy
out a little bit regarding rotations or
playing time or style or strategy i'm
talking about
like very direct line you know in game
one of of the playoffs um you know let's
let's try bobon in the starting lineup
and feeling that pressure
um or wherever whenever they started
playing bologna as a starter but
like it was not it became it wasn't
advice anymore
it was the feeling that you know if you
say no to these things
you're probably going to be on the wrong
side of things so all those
things match up to to have a guy in rick
carlisle who he's too good at this to
sit around and
stay in that environment i think he's
going to be in the mix for a lot of
these other jobs
and and obviously he choose to move on
sam amick of the athletic here who who
is bob vulgaris again
that we keep mentioning his name he's
all over your piece you refer to him as
a shadow gm
that clearly rankled mark cuban who is
this guy that that he's i mean by you
know admittedly
i've learned more by the day and you
know his public profile
is of somebody who's a wildly successful
gambler and i'm talking
poker tournaments he placed fourth in
the 2017 world series of poker
um he's he's written on the media side
about basketball
there's still a website i think it's
alone in the corner alone in the dark
something like that where
where it's got you know years old
basketball pontification
from bob um you know and he's a guy that
that uh
is has been in the media space um and
it's it's kind of a classic
mark cuban pickup because mark has
always taken a lot of pride in
being you know outside the box being
unconventional and so
those guys i don't know all the
specifics here but they're
you know i think there's been business
done between them in the past
that established that relationship and
then mark reaches the point where he
decides that his basketball views
are worth adding to the the official
mavs program but i mean
the genesis of it is that bob somewhat
publicly had shown an ability
to make a ton of money on the nba based
on the way he saw the game and
you know evaluating different teams from
the outside
and that of course led to him being on
the inside
how does the nba feel about this sam
because again you know you
you you see it i see it the number of
times that i i i get tweets in my
direction people even call the show
you know scott foster's on this game
fixes in you know
or or like where did that call come from
all the you know this guy goes to the
line 19 times the other team doesn't go
and he fixes in
because the whole donaghy stuff what do
they think about the fact that
there's somebody in the front office who
finished fourth in the world series of
poker which by the way might not mean a
damn
thing you know i play poker but you know
no but it's just the optics right like
and i'm not i mean listen this is
nothing against bob the guy's listening
doing something right
just stacking up money based on his
intellect and his abilities here but
right um if you talk about the league
and perception and optics
um for sure i think it's time for me and
personally i mean
i need to talk to the league more very
soon about how they see this
right here right now in 2021 as opposed
to you know 2018
my general understanding again is i i
don't know all the ins and outs of this
but there was there was a
fairly serious process where you know
the league obviously gave the green
light on this higher and they looked at
this from a
you know the gambling standpoint they
considered all these optics
but you know i think the part that mark
misplayed
and there's elements here not to
generalize too much but
rich you know if you go back to when you
know michael lewis wrote moneyball and
the whole theme
of analytics versus old school scouting
right you know became a major part of
sports
there's absolutely themes here that that
are consistent with that
and then you add in the gambling
component and so my opinion is that
as far as mark goes he just he did not
understand
how big of a problem a lot of his
employees had with this
from the very beginning and then and it
really did get compounded
i've been doing this a long time and i'm
not trying to it's there's nothing
personal ever in reporting but in terms
of
personal etiquette style all those
things you know i don't remember running
into a
subject that i wrote about that where it
was just not hard to find folks who
who really did not enjoy his company so
you know those
those are two big time factors to
combine and they led to
where we got here but the league you
know if i had to guess
they're needing to look at this again
and make sure they're still comfortable
with this in light of
all the knowledge that it's made senior
nba rider from the athletic sam amick
here on the rich eisen show let's finish
up with the
ultimate question here um because
they've got a unicorn
sitting there in dallas is the rest of
the league sitting there
sitting here watching this putting their
their uh their napkin tucked into their
shirts with a knife and fork thinking
that luca
could be had in a couple years what do
you think i mean
that's what teams do that's what they
always do um
you know this off season i think daniel
is that guy
that you know we're going to be
monitoring and luca
lucas is going to tell the world what
they should think
with this super max extension that that
again the information
right now is that he still intends to
sign it you're talking about
200 plus million dollars so you know if
let's say
he does sign it that's going to be a
sigh of relief
for mark and the mavs and then it's
going to be
rival teams continuing to monitor all of
it who do they
hire to head up the front office and
today's reporting coming from
the new york times and espn was that
mark has kind of
looped in all the you know the match
fans favorites dirk kavinsky michael
finley some other trusted advisors that
they had a meeting yesterday
to essentially get a game plan going
here that that feels like a very natural
smart move
but yeah teams are going to be watching
and i mean
if i was a rival executive i'd be all
over the situation every day of the week
because
the bottom line is that luca continues
to tell people around him
that this environment has been
frustrating to him and the obvious thing
here is that they lost in the first
round
two years in a row when he was pretty
transcendent and he was
fantastic and it was certainly not his
fault so to speak
so you know you know the game those
factors typically lead
to uh to drama when it comes to a star
player we'll just kind of see where this
one goes so are you saying that the
the moves in the last couple days could
actually be read
uh equally as much as we're reading it
that there's been
enough dissension that um that the
general manager is now gone
coach follows that these moves might be
made to
assure lucas signature on that super max
contract
create the circumstances for this yeah i
mean that's my own suspicion um
and i and again that's the smart play um
because
you know listen when we wrote that he
was still all indications were that he
was going to sign
the super max it's one of those pieces
of information that as i wrote it
you're kind of going all right that's
what you guys are telling me you know
but
you know i don't know because you we
heard stories right out the gate about
luca's reaction to the donny decision in
particular and he publicly talked about
it the other day he was very close with
donnie
and that's who drafted him i mean if you
look at you know the
you know the mavs organization that luca
came into versus the one
that exists now if you're a young guy
who doesn't want to waste one day one
week one year
of these special basketball years is the
last thing
you want you don't you don't want
instability you don't want chaos you
know you want to just be able to
to go make the most of your talent so i
think for sure
everything they do right now is intended
to kind of calm
luca's fears so last question for you
sam that i know you don't have the
answer to but i'll ask it anyway
uh luca drops in 66 instead of
46 in game seven we talking about this
right now do you think
um against the clippers not to this
degree i mean i i thought
listen i thought rick was back um
you know that's that was the intel
coming from his camp
um these issues we were going to write
about some version of these issues
regardless whether his second round
defeat you know this story's been in the
works for quite some time
so that stuff would get out i think bob
bulgaris would become part of the
narrative
but you know no i mean like this i think
rick
if he gets to the second round he
fosters uh
maybe a little bit more good will with
luca where you have that success
losing twice in the first round when you
were up two nothing
you know that probably was a tipping
point but
you know we'll never know but but i
think it probably wouldn't have been
this dramatic all right and i lied
that's not the last question because you
mentioned that
okay yeah here we go last one i promise
uh because you'd mentioned that this
uh non-playing season as i like to refer
to it in sports
um for the nba that the guy that it's
going to be
focused on as maybe he could be moved is
damian lillard do you really think
there's any there there
with that maybe yeah for sure um i do
and it's a little bit analogous
it's not as dramatic by any means but
it's a little analogous to the dallas
situation from the standpoint of
you know star player uh waiting and
watching to see what the organization
does
and so if the blazers in damien's
mind swing and miss on the head coach
then you have just pushed him even
farther out the door
so i you know in there's i mean listen
there's been some reporting that's been
shot down so far elsewhere
about the question of gm neil o'shea is
there any chance that
that jody allen who is now in control of
the team when her brother paul passed
away
that it'd be a front office change so so
far that does not appear to be the case
but
damien um i mean listen he i know him
pretty well covered in his whole career
he's
he's he's been moving differently lately
he put up an instagram post
right after the playoff loss talking
about you know quoting mipsy hustle and
talking about how long do i stay
dedicated
he doesn't do those things he's very
deliberate he's very calculated very
smart
so um yeah and there's certainly a lot
of smoke
right now around him when it comes to
just the general idea that if they don't
get it right
that um there might be a tough
conversation to have about what comes
next damn
that would be that would be something
i mean if portland can't win with him
you know maybe they close up shop move
to seattle i'm serious you know what i
mean like
how talented a guy can you have because
we're talking about shot making in the
playoffs and who can make a shot
and who can you depend on i mean game
time to walk it and talk it the way that
he does
if he if he essentially decides i can't
win here then how
who the hell is going to go there to win
there right i mean i'm with you
yeah wow 100 i mean you know this this
is
we could talk what ifs all day but for
me i always think back to
when the marcus aldridge decided to go
to san antonio and just
i mean who knows how far they would have
gotten but i feel like that was
unfortunate like lamarcus
got essentially intimidated by damian's
rise to start him early and
uh kind of headed for the exits you know
maybe that would have been the thing
that
at least got them to a higher level and
because you now have this totality of
frustration
from damian's part where other than the
one year when they got to the west
finals
and got swept by the warriors you know
it's been an individual profile that's
just gotten better and better better
with league wide respect and then a
collective profile that has largely been
the same
which is that okay you all win a bunch
of games but you're not really a threat
when it matters most
sam thanks for the time great reporting
great conversation let's chat down the
line
appreciate it thank you rich appreciate
it you got it that's sam amick of the
athletic sam you don't forget the
underscore that's how you can follow him
between his first and last names on
twitter
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here